[Music]  Jamie Foxx and Katie Holmes make a rare  public appearance together and we are  swooning these two can't keep their eyes  off each other at the Clive Davison  Recording Academy's pre-grammy gala in  NYC on Saturday check out Fox and home  smiling and goofing off together at the  event and eye witness tells et the duo  didn't initially sit together inside the  bash but were prompted by host Davis to  do so before taking their seats 39 year  old Holmes rocked a stunning red gown  with her hair in a super chic side-swept  pop while the 50 year old actor skipped  showing off his dapper look on the red  carpet a navy and black tuxedo well we  can't get over this rumor couple finally  letting their low-profile romance shine  you